so the other thing is same-sex marriage
there's the other thing that I think
that we disagree with
well I we agree with the marriage thing
right should be involved deal I think
where people should be protected is
through assets and you know the contract
yes yeah I think that that all makes
sense to me that all that still in terms
of like alimony and child support and
all those things make sense to me and
that and the idea that the community
reinforces it which would then become
the government reinforce and all that
stuff that all makes sense to me I
understand it but why do you care if two
gay guys want to get married um so from
a religious point of view sure let's go
for it so so I mean why would a secular
point of view first so the the idea is
not that I care deeply whether two gay
guys want to get married to each other
the idea is that it do I prefer
traditional marriage to say to same-sex
marriage okay well let me let me phrase
it this way what do you think a gay guy
is do you think someone's there making a
choice or do you think that this is how
they were born so the religious point of
view on this and I think this is
actually just the general conservative
point of view on human action generally
is I don't know meaning that for the
vast majority of people out assume that
they have a biological drive to engage
in that behavior but the traditional
sort of will point of view is that
biological drive does not necessarily
match up to the activity you ought to
engage in right men for example have a
biological drive to impregnate many
women
that's not something religion is cool
with either right so the the idea is
that rapid religion is cool with the man
being with one woman and impregnating
her but you're not cool with a man being
with a man so I can give you the
religious explanation I think we the
second what explanation so they said the
religious explanation is that there is
something different about a woman than
there is about a man and a man is made
better through his union with a woman
and that if you pervert the sex drive to
pursue your pleasure instead of a
lasting relationship upon which the
basis of society is built then you are
foregoing the proper use of your sex
drive right because you wanted to step
in and argue against that you would say
that just because someone can't get
pregnant doesn't mean that they don't
have
a loving relationship that contributes
to society well that's true but it is
also foregoing the more productive
relationship of being able to bear and
we're children and also recognizing
they're not different right and and
recognizing also the sexes are not the
same so the you know being with a man is
in a relationship different than being
with a woman I would assume I mean I
think that's why gay guys are gay if it
weren't then assume that they would be
fine with being with a woman right so
that's so that relationship from a from
a religious perspective is more valuable
because women have different qualities
than men you round off each other's
harsh edges it changes you I mean you're
married
being married changes a man in a
different way that being married to a
member the same sex would right but I
don't want people to have to do it but
if you're a mediator they're not forcing
anybody right but I want them to have
the option if you're a gay person and we
know I mean of course because legally we
agree right yeah and I keep making this
distinction cuz whenever I talk about my
moral perspective on things
mhm then people immediately assume that
I'm a theocratic fascist and I just want
to keep underscoring yes my personal
views on Dave Reubens marriage of no
consequence
to public policy in any way whatsoever
right but I agree with you on that and I
don't think it should be a part of
public policy and I think people should
absolutely be allowed to marry and
divorce and do whatever the fuck they
want to do no matter who it is but why
do you care like as a person who's a
rational thinker it's pretty clear that
people are gay and I don't really think
that this is a decision they make in
term in terms of like I'm gonna make a
clear choice to defy God and be gay I
think they're just good everyone it's a
conflation of identity and drive with
activity which is something that
religion fundamentally reject okay
religion fundamentally rejects the idea
that you're driven to do something
therefore it is your identity therefore
you get to participate in the behavior
that's it that's a chain of thinking
that really so in religion if a man is
gay in your religion yes a man is gay
and they're in love with another man
they should just squash those thoughts
and find a woman well ideally they would
be honest with the woman who marries
they're not like boasting about what
they would want ideally ideally you
would still get married and have
children in a heterosexual relationship
if you're not up to that then
wouldn't get married at all - when you
describe this to a gay man they will
tell you imagine ben shapiro if someone
said to you you should stop being with
your beautiful wife and you need to now
marry a man because this is what God
wants you to do so you're gonna have to
stoop this man and he's gonna stoop you
and because this is how the rules are
set up right well this is how it sounds
to gay folks when you're telling them
they have to find a woman and like one
I'm not saying you have to find a woman
I'm saying this guy well I'm saying you
can't do X right I'm not saying we must
but saying can but by whose
determination if you decide to
participate in this religion right then
there is a buy-in to the precepts of the
religion and the buy-in is okay well no
the buy-in is that you can have whatever
sexual orientation you please but
there's certain activity you can't
participate in so you can be gay but you
can't have gay sex correct that's that
by the way that's what the Bible I mean
if we want to go direct to the Texas
Bible that's what the Bible actually
says right I mean even the parts of the
Bible that people really hate mm-hmm
those parts say that a man shall not lie
with a man it doesn't say a man can't be
attracted to another man that's Old
Testament right yeah right that's our
stuff right New Testament it gets a
little harsher in the New Testament in
some places Romans but in any case you
know again when it comes to this is what
I'm puzzled by is the idea that this is
a unique area of human behavior that
religion is supposed to treat
differently meaning religion treats
virtually every human activity like this
sin is a failure to abide by a covenant
right that's what that's the definition
of sin right when you commit a sin in
Judaism in Avera in Judaism what you are
doing is failing to do a mitzvah which
is a commandment you're violating a
commandment well there are lots of
Commandments that go directly against
what people are driven to do just
because the drive is stronger does not
make it morally more morally non
culpable to violate that commandment so
when people pick this one out and they
say well this one is particularly
intolerant for example I don't see why
it's more particularly intolerant than
saying to a man that you have to marry
one woman or saying to a Jew that you
are not allowed to eat this stuff or you
like it's it may be harder yeah I think
there's any question it's harder to
abide by those Commandments but
it is well within religious tradition
like literally every religious tradition
that there's a bunch of stuff you are
driven to do that you can now again you
don't have to agree with my program I'm
not trying to convert you there's one of
the nice things about my religion I
don't give a crap whether people are
Jewish or not like we actively
discourage converts but if you're going
to proclaim that you are you know
abiding by traditional Judaism this is
the buy-in right there's lots of buy and
you have to wear a funny hat sometimes
you have to you have to go to shul on
Saturdays you have to keep Shabbat like
there's there's a lot of buy-in and as
long as I'm not bothering anybody else I
frankly don't see what business it is of
legitimately anybody's what I think
about personal relationships I'm not
imposing my view on anybody else
well I do acknowledge that out of all
the religions Judaism probably makes it
the the most obvious they don't give a
fuck what you do go ahead do your thing
like they're not trying to my uncle
converted and when he convert it was a
grind man he had a learn wash it like
three years it's a long time so that was
the religious perspective on that and
the secular perspective when it comes to
valuing traditional marriage over over a
same-sex marriage that's a very simple
calculation which is one type of
marriage produces traditional children
produces children in the traditional
biological way and then you have one
parents in the house to take care of the
kid right that's the value of marriage
and I fully acknowledge that when the
value of marriage shifted from it's
about production and rearing of children
to it's two people who love each other
the case for same-sex marriage against
same-sex marriage when completely out
the window right so you are just
sticking to your rigid ideology in terms
of like what you believe to be a sin and
not believed to be a sin based on your
religion based on this very strict moral
fiber that this religion is operate in a
religious context may be nice to me it
applies to my family it doesn't apply to
you right is there any room for growth
in that when people have a better
understanding about biology like if it
was proven if there's proven like oh
this is why a person develops blue eyes
this is why a person is gay this is why
there's nothing wrong with it it's just
a very it's red hair
it's freckles it's gay it's straight
tell me that that homosexual orientation
is a hundred percent biologically driven
and I will almost completely
with that I think that there are some
cases where it's not but those are rare
but this particularly by the way the
research tends to show that there's more
sexual fluidity among females than males
males it tends to be either heterosexual
or homosexual every search is all done
by dudes want their wives to hook up
with chicks but again that it's it's a
question that I've always found actually
not particularly interesting simply
because it doesn't take into account the
worldview generally which is that a
biological drive does not equal excuse
for behaving in a certain way but that's
where it brings me back to this like is
it possible that these laws in this
religion were written when they're what
mean do who do you think wrote the stuff
do you think people wrote the stuff or
do you think God wrote I think either
way even if it were I mean because I am
a an Orthodox Jew and I believe that at
the very least it's got inspired and God
written right but even if I believed on
a secular level that human being sort
that stuff - I think the people 3000
years ago had never seen a gay person
before like the very reason to have a
commandment is because certain people in
your community are behaving in a
particular way presumably right there's
no commandment not to take your head and
shove it in a meat grinder well this is
also the argument against pork is
because they didn't understand
trichinosis they understand you have to
cook the meat to 145 degrees and pork
parasites which are very dangerous for
people so I'm not a huge fan of
naturalistic explanations for religion I
think that's a good one though for pork
I mean I don't know like I think you
could make an argument maybe that it
just died in India and there was
horrific x-rays of his head he had
parasites from pork that had gotten into
his body and they had nested in his
brain started developing all these cysts
inside of his head and they couldn't do
anything about it because it was so deep
in his head that if they gave him the
anti you know anti-parasitic medication
it would cost Welling of the brain and
they were like it was it was so it's
actually pig shit apparently the people
accidentally coming in contact the pig
shit produces this particular type of
parasite
yeah that's not kosher it's more rare
but but trichinosis was pretty calm the
their attempts to sort of paint back
into the Bible certain rationalistic
explanations like this make sense though
I I think why else would you would it be
bad to eat pigs like Jesus loves pigs so
what's going on well III think that the
the reversal of the kosher laws in the
New Testament you know from from a
Jewish point of view where we don't
believe in the divinity of Christ and
that there he can make an argument that
the the Gospels which were written he
was just about fit and significant no no
we don't believe he's a prophet what do
you think he was what do you guys I mean
what I think he was historically I think
he was a Jew who tried to lead a revolt
against the Romans and got killed for
his trouble just like a lot of other
Jews at that time who were crucified for
trying to lead revolts against the Roman
and get killed for their trouble so he
became legend in story and it became a
bigger and bigger deal followers and
then that gradually grew and then they
resurrected no that's not that's not a
Jewish belief okay just one shot yeah no
there there one's the old woman yeah
you've got Moses splitting the sea and
all that what do you think happen there
what do I think happened there yeah well
I'll go with my mana D and explanation
that there was a mean it says in the
Bible there was a strong east wind so
there was a naturalistic explanation for
a physical phenomenon that makes sense I
mean that's what Maimonides is
constantly trying to do is read nature
back into the Bible mmm
yeah that that is the problem with these
texts right is that you're trying to
decipher translations from original tax
which were written in ancient Hebrew
thousands of years ago and we're told an
oral tradition for longer than that
right I mean this is this is where you
know my my book which I always hesitate
to pitch my own stuff cuz it sounds
gauche which way but the new book the
right side of history number one New
York Times best-selling non-fiction book
me you got number one in the New York
Times best-selling really yeah we sold
enough that we knocked Michelle Obama
out of the woods live for a week so is
there protests
well no protest yet but suffice it to
say the New York Times Book Review or
didn't like it but I'm not super shocked
by that but the the basic contention
that I make is that judeo-christian
values on the one hand and then human
reason on the other Greek reason really
that that tradition is attention and
that that tension is where Western
civilization lives that basically
civilization is to suspend
Brij it takes certain fundamental
precepts of judeo-christian values on
the one hand and then takes Greek reason
and they're pulling against each other
and sometimes reason feels like it's
gonna dominate religion and sometimes it
feels like religion is gonna dominate
reason and the best of all available
worlds you have a bridge that is that is
capable of building a pond where you can
actually have a functional civilization
and if you lose reason in the name of
theocracy then you end up with
tyrannical theocracy and if you lose and
if it was religion in the name of reason
you end up in some pretty dark places
because human beings don't have a very
good track record of creating their own
purpose creating their own meaning
creating their own systems we tend to
get very utopian very quickly and things
get really ugly which is sort of the
story of the particularly the first half
of the 20th century so this is the
benefit of sticking to the rigid
ideology that's prescribed by religion
is that you don't allow the human beings
to keep updating it and changing it
because if you do they will eventually
slide into chaos yes but there's there
which is not to say there's not playing
the joints there certainly religion is
morphed over time
I mean foody ism as it was practiced
originally probably in many ways does
not resemble Judaism as practice now
right in fact the Talmud even says this
I mean there's there's this kind of
fascinating and counterintuitive section
of the Talmud where Moses is it's it's
what is called the gotta tie which some
of these stories that are just kind of
put into the into the middle of the
Talmud where Moses comes back and he's
watching from on high as a bunch of
rabbis in you know second century
Palestine are talking about Judaism and
he's like I don't recognize any of this
stuff like I brought down these books
from the mountain and I do not recognize
any of this stuff and and God says to
him you know if a God says to him right
I mean this is how this is morphed and
Moses is pleased in other words he's not
Judaism has always had a common law
tradition we're using reason to try and
develop the ideas behind the
commandments and then try and extend
them or broaden them and I think that's
a good thing but you have to be careful
not to completely undermine fundamental
roots or or get rid of basic precepts in
other words you have to you have to
acknowledge there certain fundamental
truths that exist there and then there's
play as far as how those are implemented
does Judaism have one of those pray the
gay away traditions no that's
not a thing I mean it's what do they
want guys to do like what say what would
you do if nowhere not to sin but again
soon is a sin is a thing that everybody
does meaning that masturbation is not is
not okay according to Judaism I assume
that a vast majority of young Jewish men
even the Orthodox are masturbating so
people sitting I mean that's that's a
recognition it's it's always again I
think I can speak on behalf of I will
audaciously speak um I have both Jews
and Christians here I think that
religious people are told that when they
say that something is a sin this means
that they are looking askance at the
people who are committing the sin and
that is not correct I mean what Judaism
and Christianity say is that we are all
committing sins on a fairly regular
basis where we get uptight is when
people start saying because I have a
desire for the sin the sin is no longer
a sin hmm yeah the real problem is like
what why is it a sin like who says it's
a sin so again again this these rules
you were assuming are influenced by God
right
but clearly written by people well the
this one you would say if you're a
fundamentalist or at least somebody who
believes in the the idea that the Torah
was given by God was given literally by
God but again that doesn't the logic
behind the rules which you know people
like Maimonides have tried to explicate
the idea is as I said a second of this
you can do without God right this part
you can without God the human sex drive
was made to procreate with in a stable
relationship in order to protect and
have future generations of people misuse
of that sex drive in any way whether
you're talking about from masturbation
to homosexual activity is therefore a
diminishment of the use of that drive
that's the natural law case against
against homosexual activity and again I
will reiterate for media matters for the
one millionth time I'm not in favor of
any of this being encoded into American
law because freedom is freedom people
should be able to send how they choose
so long as they're not harming anybody
else right no but what about people that
have had vasectomies and what about
women that also Judaism is not cool to
second base not cool with it but neither
is Catholicism from what I understand
right right yeah well I'm not a big fan
of that one either experience with
so if what if a man is sterile and the
woman's sterile are they allowed to have
sex they'll both know so yes because
there are ancillary benefits to married
couples having sex like relationship
building right that's not a generalized
case against the favored view of sex
right that's sort of like arguing that
intersex people mean that there's no
such thing as two separate sexes there
aren't two separate sexes and also
they're intersex people who have a
condition yes right and that's the same
thing here the case in favor of
heterosexual sexual activity does not
change based on the fact that some
people can't actually participate in
that what would you do if a young gay
guy came to you for advice if someone
said hey Ben I'm an admirer of yours I
love the way think and follow your
philosophies but I've got a problem I'm
a young Jewish man and I'm gay and I
don't know what to do what would you
tell him to do I mean I can't tell them
to do anything would you advise would
you tell it would you what help them to
not act out on those feelings I would
say you do the best you can as a human
being and from my moral perspective you
try to avoid sin as best you can
mm-hmm but everybody sins the problem
does that sin though it seems to me that
it was defined by people that didn't
understand biology because they were
dealing with humans that existed
thousands of years ago I mean again I
really don't think that biblical
Commandments are linked and religious
Commandments generally are linked to a
view of biology meaning that you don't
think so no I think that all sin is a
recognition that we have drives that we
are supposed to forgo okay that's pretty
much I mean that's that's fundamental to
certainly Judaism and it's to
Christianity as well I would say Islam
even as this basic precept right when I
think we can agree that there's some
real benefits to discipline there's real
benefits to having structure and and it
doesn't mean that you can't be creative
it doesn't mean that you can't be free
and do whatever you want some of the
time too but I think we can both agree
that this is one of the one of the best
benefits of an ideology and what
hopefully a positive ideology right and
what one of the things that I the reason
I keep coming back to the governmental
regulation point is because my view is
that if your view of discipline is not
you discipline good on you right like go
do what you want to do like I've never
had a conversation with Dave Rubin about
about him being a gay guy right but you
did say that you like wouldn't go to his
marriage right well I said right as a
religious person I can't say I can't
actively participate in something that I
consider to be a sin but I would go out
to dinner with Dave and his husband any
time like my wife and I would do that of
course we'd have him over to our house
with his husband does know you don't
find any contradiction between your
religious perspective and your personal
perspective in that regard that you
would though you wouldn't be there for
religious reasons but that you would be
there for personal reasons like if it
wasn't would you go to the after-party
if you wouldn't go to the wedding would
you go to the after-party anything that
was a celebration of same-sex marriage
no wow so anything but like if we go to
the party no I mean there's a barbecue
the next day and again like I'm not sure
why I'm not a good party person so I'm
not sure why anybody would want me at
their party I haven't been to a party
with you but I went to a dinner party
with you that's right we had a great
time that was a good time that's good
that's a funny picture man that isn't I
don't know what the fuck to think about
that picture we had it's certainly true
Eric and Jordan supremacists in one
place right now all the